this is the moment
new mom elsa first saw her baby florence
there you are
hello her family feared this day
would never come
[Music]
because florence is the pandemic baby
that has survived against all odds
it's so brilliant to see you on the
other side
elsa was rushed to hospital just after
christmas
she was critically ill with covid19
and she was seven months pregnant
i remember being terrified and i was so
scared of being alone that at one point
i'd have two nurses just holding my hand
and a doctor trying to do his best to
save my life basically
elsa was admitted here to one of
kingston hospital's
intensive care units the baby was
pushing up on her lungs
and both their lives were in danger
it was heartbreaking to see a young
pregnant patient
of us in that situation we know that
most pregnant women
who are having the infection actually
are all right
elsa is one of the very very few you
know
count numbers in less than one hand who
become so unwell
uh and because of the unpredictability
of the disease
we are worried till they make that turn
around elsa was so sick
her partner tommy was told to prepare
for the worst
thinking either one of them might not be
here they both might not be
here what would that would do to our
family
but now to be here although he was so
troubling he was horrible i wouldn't
wish it on anyone
is you know it's fantastic
fantastic for us florence was delivered
on january the 5th
two months prematurely elsa was taken
back to the icu put into a coma
and onto a ventilator
when elsa was brought round two weeks
later all she wanted
was to be with her baby again it was
just
incredible just seeing how little and
fragile she was her little hands
it was just an incredible incredible
moment
i don't think any of us can even begin
to imagine what this family has been
through tommy lost his job at the start
of the year elsa
has had to shut her business down twice
and nobody
could have known if elsa and florence
would have been alive today
elsa has been discharged and is slowly
recovering from her ordeal at home
but florence must for now stay in
hospital
a few more weeks of separation before
this family
can finally be together ashish joshi
sky news at kingston hospital